- Oh my God, I love your whole outfit.
- You want me to do that again?
- I love everything! I love
everything that just happened.
Nice to meet you!
- Big fan.
- Yes! Oh, I love it. You
smell good, by the way.
I don't know what you're wearing.
- It's my skin.
- Okay.
(audience laughter)
It's eau de skin. Eau de skin.
So, meet Natasha. Meet Jake.
- Yes, great to meet you, man.
- So, you are a world famous K-pop star,
which everyone knows.
- Not really.
- Yes, you are, if you didn't know,
but I didn't know this about you.
So, originally, you were like
an athlete from Hong Kong?
- Yes, yes, yes.
- Like, fencing?
- Yeah, I was a fencer.
- Cool.
- That's cool.
- My parents, they were Olympians too.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- My dad's a fencer, my mom's a gymnast.
- Wow. So, I guess it
would have been a let down
if you didn't do something
in that category?
- Yes, I mean, I was
prepping for London Olympics
back then, and then while
prepping, I just told my parents,
"Hey, you know what? I always
had this dream about music.
Let me do my thing."
- How did that go over?
- I mean, they want me of course
to go to the Olympics,
y'know, do my thing.
And it took me seven
months to persuade them.
- Wow, but you were persistent.
That's a lot of months.
- Yeah, they were really against me.
And then they're like,
"You're out of your mind."
My principal told me that,
"This is the worst decision you're ever
gonna make in your life."
- [Kelly] Have you sent him a letter?
(audience laughter)
- I think he knows by now he was wrong.
- [Kelly] Or like a signed headshot.
- Then, after I debuted as a singer,
and I went back to have a
concert and I invited him
and he said, "Jackson,
we believed in you."
(laughter)
We believed in you.
- This happens! It happens!
That happened to me.
I was like, "What!?"
People were totally like,
"That's never gonna happen,
everybody has a dream,"
and then they were like, "the whole time."
You'd see them on the
news and they're like,
"We believed from the beginning."
And I'm like, "You are a liar!"
- "We knew you were the one" Right? Right?
- So, were your parents
worried about you guys
in the entertainment
industry? Were they worried?
- Yeah! At first, I
said, "Hey! I passed this
audition in Korea. I'm
going, I'm leaving."
And then they're like, "Entertainment? No.
They're gonna kidnap you
and put you in a cave-"
- Oh wow!
- [Kelly] What!?
- [Jackson] Y'know, like, parents.
- Yeah.
- And then they were like,
"No, you're not gonna do that.
We're not gonna see you again.
You're gonna be MIA."
And I'm like, "No, let me live my dream."
And yes, seven months of
persuading and they're supportive.
- That's amazing!
- Do we have to sit this far?
(laughter)
- You're just so cool
we're giving you room.
(audience clapping)
- [Natasha] We wanna adopt him!
- [Kelly] We were giving you room.
- Nobody's gonna kidnap ya, son.
There's no caves for you,
you made it, kid!
You made it, kid!
- Unless it's really a
cool cave, with a bar.
So, your new album is called
"Magic Man." Why that title?
Which is also a good song
by Heart, just saying.
- The whole thing is
about a journey of finding
and exploring the new
me and deciding to drop
everything - whoever I
was, whatever I had before.
To be as raw as possible that
I have ever been in my life.
The album is called "Magic
Man," it's not just about music.
The tone, the color, the
attitude, the visuals,
everything in one package and
that's who I am right now.
- Are you into all of that?
'Cause some artists aren't
into the whole thing,
like into the art, into the
all of it, like the videos...
- No, I just wanna be me 'cause like
even though it fails, it could be bad,
people can't relate to it,
but at least I won't regret it
'cause it's me, y'know?
- Someone said that to me
once the other day, like,
"You're a sinking ship." And I was like,
"Well, I'm still the captain,
so if it's gonna go down,
it's going to be because of me."
And I'm not, by the way, I'm sorry!
Write you a letter!
It's one of those things where
I feel like in this industry,
I can only speak for the music side of it,
people do that. They
try and force you to be
whatever is popular or whatever,
and I kinda wanna do what
I'm feeling right now,
and it might be successful.
I feel like every career does
this anyway, so it's fine.
I love that you're knowing that so young.
- I'm not young anymore.
- You're young comparatively speaking.
So tell us about your new single.
It's called "Blow," right?
- Yes, that's the intro
of the whole album.
It's another world that I'm
trying to bring all my audience
to - yeah, "Blow." This is "Blow."
- [Kelly] I know, it's
amazing! This video is amazing.
- [Jake] Beautiful, man.
- [Jackson] If you have
time, please check it out.
- [Jake] I have, yeah,
I listen to your music.
- Well, if you have time,
please check it out.
- I will do anything you
say. I wanna adopt you.
- [Kelly] And take you to her cave.
- He's so vulnerable and cute!
- This is how it starts, and
then you end up in a cave.
- We are those who kidnapped-
- Oh, that was what my
parents were talking about!
- You can live in my closet.
- Don't do it!